So so far.
Here's what we've done.
We've been studying the whole time,
this analog of Newton's law.
How week was I alpha,
so after teaching you what towers and what I is and what Alpha is.
In the early days I concentrated on problems where Tau is not zero.
That is some object on with some tarps that acting and in response to the
torques
and response to the torques,
the body will accelerate.
Then we went to another class of problems where there are no external torques.
It only talks from inside.
Excuse me,
will you people who come late use the other door?
Yeah.
You're blocking actually the taping right now.
Yes.
All right,
so
today I'm going to consider an extreme case where that is not target or
there's no target.
We Know Alpha is zero and the angular velocity is funds,
but I'm going to take a case where even angular velocity is zero.
There is no emotion,
there is no chart.
So you can say you know what's there to study.
Well,
sometimes it's a great interest to us that the object has no angular velocity.
Common example is you are trying to do something in your house,
you get up on a ladder or somewhere there,
uh,
this ladder should have no angle of velocity,
right?
That is a,
that's not a trivial statement to person who is going up there.
So you want to ask what does it take to keep the ladder from falling over?
Okay,
that's what we're going to discuss.
All right,
so let me start with the simple problem and take some horizontal rod like this.
And I say what does it take to keep the rod from moving around?
And the first thing you know is the forces on it should add up to zero because
otherwise f equals I may tells you this rod is going to be flying off somewhere.
So I've taken a body that rod of Linkedin and I don't want it to move at all.
So totally forces adding up to zero we know is not good enough because he had a
problem where I applied to forces equal an opposite add up to zero.
But that doesn't,
that doesn't do it.
This rod will still rotate.
It is still true that when the total force adds up to zero,
the center of mass will not accelerate.
But that doesn't mean the body will not move because keeping the center of mass
fixed,
the body can rotate.
All right,
so you have to ask yourself,
what does it take to keep it from rotating?
Then we know that the concept rotation is a torque.
So I'm going to write down now the conditions for our body,
a planar body laying in the plane of the blackboard to stay still and not move.
They are that all the forces in the x direction.
I use some labor force number one first number two,
natural data,
zero,
all the forces in the Y,
that action that should add up to zero this and make sure that central mass as a
whole is not going anywhere.
And finally the keep the body from moving or spinning.
All the parks should add a position.
So bulk of the lecture today will just be dealing with this condition.
So what are we going to study today is a collection of objects that are somehow
subject to variety of forces but still in equilibrium,
in static equilibrium.
That means they are not moving.
So simplest problem from the family is a seesaw.
Let's say that to a point where the CSI supported and let's say we put one kid
here applying some force f one f one is the AMG for the kid
and let's say this end,
you say distance x one from the support.
The question is,
oh,
how much of a kid should I put here to keep this in balance?
It should not move under the combined weight of these two kids.
So I take the body and it right down on the forces on it.
So I have f one coming down here at f two
there.
Then that is of course that cannot be the whole story because [inaudible] not
going into the ground.
That is the support and a normal force from the support
and the these two forces together should conspire to keep the body in
equilibrium.
So let's see.
So here's what I want you to understand.
F One is known.
Let's give it some name,
100 newtons.
This distance x one is also known that this is x two is also known.
I'm planning to find out what force F two is needed.
So F two is what I'm trying to solve for.
So I write all the equations I know.
So how does on telly,
there's nothing going on.
So it's zero equals zero
in the vertical direction,
I have f one pushing down,
pushing down equals n
and that's not going to be enough to solve this problem because I have two
unknowns.
I don't know.
Anne and I don't have to,
I just know this guy.
So that's where the park equation's gonna come in?
No.
Yeah,
this is a Saturday.
When you do the Torque in this problem.
So how'd you find the target?
Do you do any force?
Can you tell me what you're supposed to do?
Yeah.
Yes.
You,
yes.
Right.
What are,
should I use for this force?
Pardon me?
X One.
Uh,
okay.
Why did you choose that?
Okay.
Her answer was,
that's the pivot.
So I chose the distance.
The point is when we say the body has no net torque with means,
it's not rotating around some axes,
if that is an access around with the body is rotating than being on how to take
the torque through them.
That access when a body is not rotating,
it's not the trading about any access whatsoever.
So you can say it's not rotating through an accident I had brought through here.
So I will take all the target,
the SPEC that point seminars can say no,
it's not rotating to that either.
I will take all parks from that point.
If you change your mind on value,
you're taking the torque than the talks are all changing because in the force
time,
distance,
the distances are going to change.
So now we have a predicament where for every possible point around which I
computer Torque,
I will get a condition involving the different forces and the distances from
that point.
So I can write down the infinite number of equations for each different choice
of pivot point.
But I only have two unknowns.
F Two and n
two unknowns can only satisfy two equations,
not 2000 equations.
So we got to the hope that the extra equations I get by varying the pivot point
all say the same thing and that's what I will show you.
Now I will show you
first that if you have a bunch of forces that add up to zero,
okay,
then it doesn't matter around which point you compute the torque.
If it was zero on one point [inaudible] around any other point,
suppose I picked some point here and I take each force,
multiply the distance of that force from that pivot point and they added up to
zero.
Now you come along and say,
no,
I want to take the target on that point,
what you will be computing will be the same force but to every exci you will add
a distance.
A is the distance way which you moved your access.
No,
let's open this out.
You will find it is f I x plus a time,
some of all the FIS.
This is zero because for me the target on that point managed and this is zero
because all the forces add up to zero.
In other words,
if you find any one point and make sure the products around that point don't
cause live,
they all add up to zero.
Then the torque around any other point,
we'll also add a zero provided the sum of the forces adds up to zero and of
course that's the problem you're looking at.
So you got to realize that when you take the Torque,
you may pick any point you like.
Now that's where the strategic issue comes up.
If you were to ask simply to find what f two is,
not to completely solve the problem,
which would be also finding what the normal forces,
someone said,
just find f two I don't care what Ennis,
then that's the particular choice of pivot point that is optimum.
That choice is the one in which this normal force doesn't get to enter the
torque equation.
And I think you all know what I mean.
Pick the that point is the point around which you take the torques than n drops
out.
But this is the usual model.
When you take torques,
always take the torque through a point where
an unknown forces acting because the unknown fourth doesn't contribute to the
target equation.
So in principle you can take the target on any point and you can satisfy
yourself in your spare time.
It doesn't make matter which point you take.
Uh,
it'll be the more complicated way to solve the problem because and will come
into the picture and know and asked you what Ennis.
So we pick the point of support and then of course here's the point of support
and what did I have f one here at distance x one I had have to at a distance x
two this is the point around with them doing the torques and doesn't count.
Then you get the condition f one x one equals f two extra
from that you can solve for f two for example,
if this was one meter and this was six meters and this was a 10 newtons here,
then 10 times one has to be six times f two
so 10 equals six f two F two will be 10 over six news
I don't want to use and because uh,
and it's all sustaining for the force here.
That's what we find have to,
once you found f two in case you want to know what is the support going through,
you know,
how much load is it carrying?
You can come back now and add F1 which was given to you and the f two you then
solve for.
Then if you want to,
you can find it.
Even if you were asked to find and it's best to first take torque around the
point and so end doesn't enter,
find f two then it's very trivial to at f one and f two to get at.
This is the easiest prototypes.
Guys have to know how this is done.
Everything I do will be more and more bells and whistles on the simple notion of
how to take the torque.
All race.
No,
I'm going to take a slightly more complicated problem.
So here's a wall and that is it.
Rod here off length,
l and mass m
and it's supported by some kind of pivot on the wall and I want to hold it up by
supporting it here with the force f
and the question is what form should they apply?
Okay.
So
we know that if I draw the free body diagram of the ride,
I have my force F
I have gravity acting down everywhere on the ride.
Then the pivot,
namely the wall,
it can exert a certain vertical force.
It can also exit a horizontal force.
No one tells you the wall is frictionless at anything or the pivot is
frictionless.
So the wall is exerting in general of force.
It just had some oblique angle which are broken up conveniently in horizontal
and vertical parts.
What about gravity and
the target due to gravity is what I want to discuss.
No.
First of all,
I am only asking you to find the force I have to apply to support the rock.
So just like the other problem,
I'm not asking you to find Vnh.
So the trick once more is to jump straight to the torque equation.
Forget about the force equation,
the [inaudible] equation,
and take the target on this point.
Then this guy is out.
No matter what's going on,
doesn't matter that are due to the pivot is out.
So we have to equate that park due to the forest.
They apply to the torque due to gravity pulling the rod down dark here to force.
I apply that Torque is equal to f times the length of the ride
because it's f times r time.
The sine of the angle between them and sign up.
The angle is night is sign of 90 which is one.
How bout the torque due to the pull of gravity?
Anybody know what we're supposed to do here?
Yep.
Yeah,
we'll homogeneous [inaudible] central.
Okay.
Now why is that?
Why is it okay to replace the Torque by you?
The center of mass?
Yep.
Either of you can answer,
yes
[inaudible]
right,
but why am I allowed to pretend?
See,
we can pretend a lot,
but if it occasionally has to correspond to reality so that it works,
so why?
Why is it okay to pretend that's the correct answer?
Cool.
Uniform density,
right,
but if I really wanted to prove it,
somebody has a way to really nail it down and show that it's okay.
Yes,
rod is a bunch of little thank you.
your answer's right,
but I'm just going to,
I know where you're going.
That's the right answer.
Look,
what you want to do is you always have to go back to first principles.
You cannot take anything on faith because you picked it up on the street or
someone whispered this to you and not good enough.
That's the one lesson I want to show you throughout these lectures is I cannot
invoke new laws or new principles.
The only principle we know is f equals Ma.
You got to go back to that all the time.
Of course there's the other principle that gravity's and extra force in the
body,
but this is an extern,
this an extended object.
It's got a center of mass,
but gravity's not necessarily acting.
It's pulling each part of it down.
So I want to show you that in the end of course the answer is as if all the mass
for concentrated here for the purposes of topics.
But I want to show you why.
So the trick of proposed by this gentleman here,
imagine dividing the rod into tiny pieces,
each of which is small enough to say it as a definite location XII.
Yeah,
the Torque due to gravity acting on that little fellow is the mass of the Little
Guy Times x times g because mg is the force in mdms.
Exxon is the torque.
You want to sum it over all the little pieces,
some of our eyes summing over all the little pieces.
So let me make my life easy or dividing by the total mass and multiplying by the
total mass.
If I started this combination,
am I excise some though?
Right?
Divided by M,
that is the center of mass.
So it does look like mg x,
where x is the center of mass of the Rod.
No,
the rod really,
it doesn't have to be uniform for me to say this.
It doesn't have to be uniform.
Right?
The mass can be distributed anyway.
It likes each and mind need not be the same,
but it's very important that gravity be constant.
We demand that the force of gravity have a constant value over the length of the
rod and it's not obvious.
There's always true.
I mean if I took a tiny rod,
force of gravity is constant,
took a very big rod,
comparable,
decisive,
the earth.
Of course the pull of gravity is bearing on the length of the room,
but for all Robertson in the laboratory scale,
that's not enough.
It's not an issue and that's where this result comes from.
Okay,
so now that we know whether is all comes from,
we will now apply it in the torque equation.
This is the target.
You're the four say apply FX that's big equal two mg times x,
but exit the location of the center of mass.
Now that is going to be half the link to the right.
I'm sorry.
This FX is fl.
Okay.
We
canceled the l.
Then you find the force at play is m g divided by two.
Yep.
If the people that is exerting what force
they get,
that credit has a horizontal.
Yeah,
but it won't cost a torque.
You're finding like the net,
uh,
I am finding no,
he had,
what I'm calculating is not the net force and finding the torque.
Our own this point,
you're the pull of gravity on the different segments that make up the rock.
Can I get that?
But like why?
Oh,
but the pull of gravity is straight down and the separation is horizontal.
That the question though,
I want to know about what's your plan?
Well,
I'm,
Oh,
the force I'm applying.
I'm applying a force here.
Straight up.
Oh,
you want to know?
Ah,
well you're quite right.
You're saying we don't know a priority,
but at the force I'm applying is vertical or horizontal,
right?
Maybe that's your question.
That's actually a valid question.
It's clear that I have to play where they can force and possibly a horizontal
forced to compensate this one need that is horizontal force in the wall.
You're quite right.
Absolutely correct.
So this f I should also divide the force that I apply into vertical part,
I call f and a horizontal part that I call it Brian.
Then it'll turn out that in this problem in its prime is not needed.
You can start off telling to doubly,
if you're holding up a plank,
you know one end is anchored and you're trying to support.
It is enough to apply vertical force,
but I don't have to presume that a,
so if you want,
you can think of applying horizontal force.
It's not necessary to hold this in equilibrium.
Maybe the main point is a purely vertical force will suffice to keep this in
equilibrium is the point that I'm making.
In fact,
if that force is equal to mg over to it won't rotate.
Now we can go back.
Now that I find the force I have to play in this direction at what the forces at
the pivot,
but the vertical force on the pivot is pointing up.
My fourth that I calculated is pointing up and together they should add up to
mg.
No ma'am.
Fse called mg over to,
so the vertical force will be mg over to.
Now,
how does Auckland Force in this problem?
There is no need for you to apply the horizontal force.
There's no need for the pivot to fight you back with a horizontal force.
It's not needed for the equilibrium,
but suppose you insisted,
not only are they lifting it,
but you're leaning into the Rod.
Yes.
Then you will apply horizontal force.
It's not going to contribute the torque equation,
but if you push it in there,
the walls got to push you out and eight prime will be equal to eight.
Okay?
In fact,
let's turn to a problem where the support in fact exerts a horizontal and
vertical force,
so that's the next level of difficulty.
This is one of the standard problems in this section and it goes like this.
You had a set a rod?
Yeah,
and are supported by a wire
and the wire has certain tension.
T is anchored to the wall.
The length of the rod is El Moussa,
the artist am
and I.
The this end is some pivot which is exerting some unknown forest which can have
a horizontal and vertical part.
You'll have a whole design depart and the vertical part B.
Now I know for sure doesn't horizontal part I think you can tell.
Can you guys tell in your mind whether it's horizontal part,
this force that supporting it is pushing the rod into the wall and also pulling
it up.
The part that's pushing it to the left has to be compensated by h.
What's up boys?
The question they ask you is what does the tension on that rope
and suppose that's the crucial issue because of the tensions.
Too much rope is going to break if you want only the tension.
Once again,
the trick is forget the force equation.
Go to the park.
Equation is we go to the torque equation.
You banish both VNA.
I hope that's clear to all of you.
A force going through the pivot point in any direction is incapable of producing
any torque that's so intuitively clear.
We need not belabor that.
If you want a formula in f times r time signed data Arctic zero so we don't care
what the angle is.
So once again we'll take parks around this point and see what it will tell us.
So the tar due to gravity,
we all agreed we can now replace by AMG l over to turning it this way.
So this force exerts a torque which is equal to the value of the tension,
the length of the Rod and sine of the angle between the two,
which is this angle here.
So the nice thing is you can solve for the tension theoretically in one shot,
which is this mg over to sine theta.
That's why data cannot be too small.
If data's too small or some point p will become so large that the string will
break.
So we knew we wanted to anchor a sign.
You got to try to take a big angle like that.
So that same data is not too small,
so one of the problems you could be asked is what's the minimum angle so that
the rope doesn't break.
Given that it can support a maximum tension of thousand newtons.
Well then you put a thousand newtons here,
you know the m and the g,
you saw it for the data,
which it crosses those newtons and your data should be bigger than that.
Yep.
Where do you get the fact that Derek is equal to that?
That was the definition of the torque.
If you go back then you got to go back to what we did earlier than you will
find.
I did use the other day.
I said maybe I'll remind you how that happened.
I'm trying to find the analog of f equals Ma analog of Mas.
I alpha and I said,
who is the guy who can play the role on the left hand side and I found the
quantity that plays the role of IMF that's equal I l four is the first time,
distance time signed data.
Okay,
so that you look,
you got to understand why torque has assigned data in it.
If you want to rotate the body,
take anybody that you want to rotate,
you know here is a rod and you want to rotate it.
You pick a point,
you want to play a force.
We know intuitively that any force applied along this direction,
there's no use in terms of rotating it.
The best way to apply a force of a given magnitude is to be perpendicular to it,
but if for some reason you can only apply some angle,
then this part of the forest is good for rotation and that part of the forest is
not good for rotation and the scientist projects out this part,
if that angle is data,
that FCI data is really the perpendicular part of f.
So that's how the tarp was defined.
Okay,
so we found the tension here.
Yeah,
if that's all you want to know,
that's the end of the problem.
You got attention,
but you may be asked to do more.
You could be asked to now find what's happening at the pivot.
Then you've got to go back to the forces.
So in the horizontal direction in the x direction,
the total forces have to add to zero.
So eight should be equal to f.
It should be equal attention time,
school signed data because this tea has a t sine theta that way and the tico
same data that way.
Okay.
And this is tico scientists.
So tico Santana is pushing in the wall should push out and now I know the value
of tea.
I put that in mg over to cotangent data because their school sign oversight.
All right,
so that's the horizontal part.
How about the vertical park in the vertical direction?
Upward vertical force plus design data has to be the downward force,
which is AMG.
Yeah,
well we know what the scientists is.
We just did that.
These scientists,
if you look up here,
do you signed it as mg over two
equals AMG.
That means V's mg over to
that means a pivot.
Provoke provides half the support,
half the mass and the tensions vertical part provides the other part.
So I will give you a couple of seconds to think about this.
This is the kind of problem you guys should be easily able to do.
You isolate the Rod,
you write all the forces on it.
If you want.
Maybe this,
if this pixel is not clear to you,
what I have in mind is I pull out the rod and say,
why is this rod not turning and moving under all the forces acting on it.
Then I read the forces on it.
Uh,
the tension is acting in that direction.
The pivot has a vertical force pivot as horizontal force and gravity.
For this purpose I will replace as acting there under the action of all these
forces that are artist,
neither translating,
not rotating.
That means the x component of the foresight to zero.
The white component answer to zero,
the tar cats disease.
If you've got to the equations,
you can plug the numbers into any of them in any order you like.
In the end,
you'll all get the same answer,
but the way to get the answer to most effectively is to take the torque equation
because the beauty of the target equation is that neither the vertical partner,
they horizontally part,
not anything to do with the pivot enters that,
so bear that in mind.
Now you can embellish the problem.
I don't want to do that.
You can hang a weight here.
I don't think that should cause any problem support.
There's an extra way to little m on top of the mass of the Rod.
I'm actually hanging.
You wait here.
Well,
all you have to do when you go to the torque equation is to remember that this
weight going this way,
we'll provide an extra torque.
There'll be little m times g times the whole length of the rod because I'm
taking the target on that point.
You put that in new salt for the tension t.
Then go back and again do the first part.
Any questions about this so far because I'm going to do now the last of these
equilibrium problems before I do something else.
The last year,
the equilibrium problem.
It's very standard fair for this course,
which is the problem I mentioned in the beginning to motivate all of this and
that is if I have a ladder leaning on a wall,
awesome angle data,
you're going ask yourself,
is that a limit to the data?
You think that's going to be some kind of limit and if so,
what kind of limit?
Will it be a lower limit or an upper limit?
What do you like to guess?
A lower limit on the Taita.
By that you mean what if data is less than some amount?
What will happen?
It'll fall very good.
So for,
for equilibrium there'll be a lower limit on data.
I think it's clear to all of us that if you trying to claim a building and you
put a ladder like this years asking for trouble,
right?
Yup.
No,
I agree.
You mean 91 degrees lateral like this?
Yes.
I agree with you.
I don't recommend that either.
So between are you a mathematician because they always find out something wrong
in anything I say,
I say good morning.
They say,
well,
not quite.
You know,
let's look into this.
Philosophers even more difficult.
What is good?
What is morning?
It's morning here.
It's my time in California,
but look,
every time I make up an exam for a question,
I ran it by a lot of students,
a lot of TA's.
Because when I'm talking to you,
I have a certain notion of what I'm talking about,
but the same words can mean something else and quite often I am tripped up by
this though.
This is the first time at this question has come up so you learn something
everyday.
All right.
Anyway,
let's say we are going to limit ourselves zero to 90 and what angle can it take?
What's the minimum angle?
What do you think is going to control that angle?
Yep.
Yes.
The court between the what?
Right.
Okay,
so in fact it turns out even the conference,
the friction with this wall may help,
but we are going to rely on a problem,
but the wall is frictionless and the floor has the friction and it's got a stat,
static friction mew,
which I'm just going to give to you.
So here to summer challenge.
Now we want to see why this arrived.
It's not falling,
so let's just write down all the equations so whenever they get any irritation
problem.
Rule number one is don't panic.
Just write down the three great conditions and it'll all happen.
The first condition is a well zero conditioners.
Draw the forces on this guy.
So what forces do you want to draw?
I think we have learned over and over.
AMG can be assumed to be acting in the middle of the Rock Center of the Rod.
The Wall is very important.
If it's a frictionless wall,
then the only force that can exert is perpendicular to itself.
That's the meaning of frictionless.
You cannot apply a force along the length of the Rod,
so let's give that nameW or a wall.
Yeah,
I come to the floor.
Now the floor is exerting a force and standard name,
flip normal or perpendicular.
Then it's exerting a frictional force F,
which will be inward because the ladder,
the strange was slide out.
You will apply a static friction force inward to keep it from moving.
That's it.
These are the forces and subject to these forces.
We have to write down all the conditions,
the Sangha list data here
for the x motion.
The fact that all the,
maybe I should write it,
some of all the ex forces is zero.
Simply says w equals f.
Some of all the white forces equal tells me n equals g,
right?
All that is left with the torque and that's where you have the choice.
You can take the torque around any point you like.
You can take that point.
In fact,
you can take a point here,
okay.
If you want to really punish yourself,
you can take a target on some crazy point and then an f will all come into the
problem and you will have to work that much harder.
So the trick again,
take the Torque here than an effort gone.
And what do I have?
I have MD try and rotate it this way.
I've w trying to rotate it that way.
I'm just going to balance the magnitudes of the two torx.
So what equations will they get for W it is w times l claim signed data.
Now here is where you shouldn't simply write it down.
You got to make sure that you would have written this down.
Going back to the definition of Torque force times distance from the pivot point
times the sine of the angle between the force and the line of separation.
W is the force,
the distance is l the length of the ladder and this state and that pay the equal
by some theater.
And we learned in high school that if you've got two parallel lines,
the angle is the same.
So the [inaudible] are you want to use as that.
That's the torque.
That's the duty at the wall.
The tarp due to gravity is mg l over to co signed data.
Now wait,
do they write co-signed data?
Am I making a mistake instead of signed data?
Why is it cause signed data?
Oh yes.
Cause that angle ladder is,
yeah.
So let me repeat the answer.
They knew,
right?
Torque is MGL signed data.
That data is not some fixed angle that somebody drew in the diagram.
It varies from forced to force.
It's the angle that force makes with the line connecting the point of
application of the force of the point of rotation.
So mg is acting here.
You want the angle between the bad x and of MD and the dynamics and of the line
of separation,
which is this angle.
So you really want to sign of this angle but sign up that angle is costly of
this angle
so you can cancel that.
I find w equals AMG over to core tangent theta.
Yes.
The torque equation tells me that's the Wy need.
The Wall's going to push out with that w and you better be able to fight that
the fight that that w should be equal to f just what we got here.
That's fine too.
But now we have a restriction.
F cannot be arbitrarily big.
F is less than or equal to the Coefficient of static friction times the normal
force.
Yup.
You explain.
Yes.
So I wanted to find the torque due to the force of gravity acting.
Then with respect to this point,
by the definition of the Torque,
you take the force,
you're joined the point of application of the force of the point around which
are doing the torque and take the angle between those two lights.
So it's really that angle,
which is not the taper here.
But if I draw the picture here,
you can see this is data,
this is 90 minus data,
this angle that I want.
But then sign of 90 minus data is called same data.
And that's why you use that
sign up 90 minus status quo.
Same data.
Because when you change data at 90 minus theta watch becomes what's opposite
becomes our Jason and I.
Jason Becomes opposite in any right triangle if that's your angle,
that's called the adjacent side.
But if that's your angle,
that's not the ideas inside.
So sign and cosign exchange places when data goes to 19 minus data.
All right,
so coming back again,
I did this cancellation,
I got that to be equal to the force of friction,
but that's bounded by this.
But I know n equals MD.
So bring this equation here.
So that's equal to news times mg.
So I have the restriction that empty quarter empty over to coordinate Taito.
So let's compare that.
Did that.
And we find the restriction that mg over to court and then data less than or
equal to u s times mg
cancel the mg and you find corta engine data
has to be less than or equal to two times from us.
I like to write it as 10 data has to be bigger than that equal to one over two
times for us.
Do you know how he went from here to here?
If this number is smaller than this,
the reciprocal of this number is bigger than the reciprocal of this.
Number three is smaller than ten one third is bigger than one 10th same thing.
So I'm somehow used to tangent better than with cortex.
And so I flip this over and I flipped that over and also change less than two
bigger than this way we can understand Panthera has to be bigger than some
number.
That means data has to be bigger than some number because canthia increases with
Taylor.
So you tell me what your coefficient of friction is.
Maybe it's 0.5 then this is one 10th dealers should be bigger than one data
should be bigger than 45 degrees.
Okay.
Are a Pi over four
maybe I should keep using radiant.
So you guys get used to radiants as the way to think about it.
So what's the famous show and CNN?
Anderson Cooper.
What?
Anderson Cooper two Pi.
Cause that's what it is for this class.
Think gradients.
Are you going to screw up somewhere?
Okay.
Angle is what we use every day.
But radiants what we use here,
when I write a 10 data,
and I don't tell you what it is or if I tell you tangential velocity is Omega
Times are that velocity,
angular velocity.
Omega is Radians per second.
A lot of people get tripped over this,
okay?
It's a very natural way to measure angles and you guys get used to that.
Okay?
So this is a collection of problems all in the x,
y plane.
Rigid body dynamics is quite manageable as long as everything license the x,
If the plane of the black borders,
the x,
y plane,
notice that everything is happening.
The X,
y plane,
all the mass is concentrated on the plane.
All the forces are on the plane,
all the vectors separating.
The point of the Torque to the point of the forces in the plane,
but now you have to deal with the fact that in real life objects are not just
planners,
they are chunks like a top or a potato.
So living in three dimensions and rigid body dynamics and three dimensions,
one of the most complicated fields.
Uh,
so we're not going to do that.
We're going to take a rather simpler version of the rigid body problem.
Basically the problem of torques and forces in three d but applied in a very
limited context,
limited context I've set for myself right now is to just apply to a single point
mass.
What does the analog of Thai [inaudible] equals I alpha when the mass is not
moving the x,
y plane,
but just running around all over three dimensions.
How do we define torque?
How do we define Anglo momentum in three d?
You will find that as a,
it's not a straightforward extension.
You have to think a little harder.
Let me motivate the problem.
We have supports.
I have a spot in the x white plains,
right?
It's a sheet of metal or something.
And it is
spinning and it Torque is applied here.
This is our and a force emphasis on life.
Yes.
The second the problem we have been studied,
we know that the Torque in this case is going to rotate it in a counter
clockwise direction if the force or opposite alerted it in a clockwise
direction.
So whenever I did a toric calculation,
the torque West Ada plus something or minus something plus men counterclockwise
minus man clockwise,
if I got 10 different torques,
I just add up all of them with proper attention to plus and minus signs.
But now imagine that this body is actually,
you don't even need a potato for this.
This take the same flat sheet,
but there's now not living in the x y plane but floating somewhere in space.
And somewhere there honors surface is a force pulling it with the separation are
what does that Torque do?
The torque will certainly provide a counter.
Uh,
let me see a counterclockwise rotation.
But around this axis
piercing the sample so we know it's counterclockwise,
but enough it's not enough to say it's counterclockwise because in this problem
it is counter clockwise around that axis.
So when a body is rotated in more than two dimensions,
the body will tend to rotate around an axis,
either clockwise or counter clockwise,
but they access itself has to be specified
as long as your body was stuck to the x,
y plane,
it had to rotate around the Z axis.
I'm just telling you if a liberate the condition and throw it in free space like
a Frisbee Frisbee can rotate at any instance.
Here's the flying frisbee is rotating around some access.
So in order to say that the Torque is producing rotations,
they want to characterize not only the magnitude of the Torque,
but also tell you the direction in which it will produce rotations.
So that is a trick we use.
The trick is we are going to somehow indicate that the effect of this store is
to produce a rotation around that axis.
So we are going to introduce a new vector Tau Tau,
which is so far a scalar is going to be now promoted to a vector
and the vector will be denoted by this symbol called the cross product.
But I will not tell you how to get towers director we know are and we know f or
the Torque we suddenly learn is actually a vector
barely fits the vector.
It needs a magnitude and it needs a direction.
The magnitude of the vector is the old thing for sine theta.
Okay,
I hope you people understand that in three dimensions,
even in three dimensions if odd,
an f four two vectors,
you know they can move around like these two fingers did define a plane and in
that plane that is a clear angle between these two vectors.
That's the angle.
I mean so he is the vector are if you want a extend,
the vector are like that.
That's the day that I'm talking about.
Now once you have two vectors,
defining a plane is one vector here and I did a vector that is perpendicular to
that plate.
Every plan has a perpendicular.
There's only one ambiguity.
He said,
if I give you something planner like this,
I can draw two perpendicular perpendiculars,
one going up and one going down both at perpendicular to the plane.
So we have to make a choice on what direction I want associated with this top.
And that's where you use the right hand rule.
The rule says there are lots of names for this room.
Ah,
let's first take a simple case.
It is our,
and let me bring the f back then and ride like this.
I wanted to find the cross product.
Our Cross F is magnitude is this length of our length of f.
Sign up the angle.
I'm trying to pick a direction.
Either the direction in this case is going to be out of the blackboard or into
the blackboard.
And the convention is stayed at in many different ways.
One convention is you take this are and you turn a screwdriver from ripe from
art to f k you guys,
imagine in your mind,
take a screwdriver,
turn the screwdriver from art f,
which way will this?
That's right.
You see,
that's what all the rap guys are doing.
They're trying to use the right hand rule because right hand rule says that if
you ever are,
and if you have an f that's the tar.
I have not followed the lyrics pretty closely,
but I believe they're muttering something about forces and torques.
Okay,
so here it is.
Here's the right 10 rule.
If this is our and that is f and that's the Torque,
but I find it much easier to do another right hand rule,
which is the witness like this.
You can see that in books to curl your fingers.
The rule says from art to F and whichever way your thumb points,
that's the direction of our cross.
I think it's pretty clear that if you write it that way,
our cross f this minus f Cros are,
so you've gotta be very careful when you take this cross product,
the audit in which you multiply directors.
Very important.
Okay,
so in this example,
our cross fit you guys ready?
Now you should have made,
I'm not going to tell you the answer,
but think for a second.
Our Cross.
In this example,
if you turn a screwdriver or do the right hand rule is coming onto the
blackboard,
that is the direction of the torque.
You can imagine these two vectors which are then the x,
y plane,
lift them up and turn them into free space.
It doesn't matter.
They still define a perpendicular direction uniquely by turning the screwdriver
from art to effort,
curling your fingers,
doing whatever you want.
That's the direction of Torque.
Torque is a vector
by the way.
That's an accidental property of living in three dimensions.
If you take two vectors a and B,
we can define across product c equals a cross fee.
The rule for what C is equal to is that the length of c is the length of a
length of be.
The sine of the angle between them and the direction of c is found by taking the
plane and with a and B lie and drawing a perpendicular to the plane in the sense
that you rotate a screwdriver from a to B.
If you're living in four dimensions.
If I give you two vectors like these two fingers,
well that's the perpendicular to it.
You can see but there's one other whole fourth dimension.
You don't see the four dimensions that is not one perpendicular direction to a
plane.
There are two perpendicular directions so you cannot take the cross product and
turn it into a vector in four dimension is a beautiful property of three
dimensions.
That one is able to take two vectors and manufactured from them at third vector
so that's an accident of three d but we live in trees so we explored this a lot
and it's a natural quantity to bring in.
When you talk about torques now the whole cross product is something one can go
on and on.
I don't want to talk for too long.
Let me just point out a couple of properties in the cross product.
One is that a cross B is equal to minus v Cross a because when he turned a
screwdriver from ADB it advances one way.
If it's B two eight goes the other way.
One particular consequence of this is that a across is zero.
Yeah,
because a cross it is minus eight cross a what that means the across eight zero.
It also follows from the fact that the angle between a and a zero degrees,
so the science data managers,
if you want to get practice,
you can practice some simple cross products.
Here's a unit vector and I,
here's a unit vector Jay,
here's the unit vector cake,
so let's try,
I crossed Jay,
I crossed this a vector perpendicular to ing,
namely pointing in the z direction,
who's length is equal to one times one time sign of 90 which is one that for
this is a non other than k
I crossed j is k but that's equal to minus of deer cross Psi.
If you went from day to I turned a screwdriver from J to why this group,
we'll go down the Z axis I across j and j crowns,
I are opposite of each other and I cross eyes.
By the way,
you will find with your hands one turn would be easy.
Other would require all kinds of contortions.
So what I suggest you do,
do it for the easier one and then flip the sign.
Cause I saw you going through some,
uh,
an honestly a tournament in the front row.
I have the same problem I've seen people doing,
you know,
at my age I should even be doing the cross product because you're going to end
up in the hospital.
So anyway,
it's a game for the young,
you can do the cross product your way,
but one day you will learn to follow my way,
which is do the easy product,
then turn the sign around.
All right,
so I don't want to spend too much time,
but let me just mention one thing because the homework problem.
Remember the dark product,
I said it's a dot.
B is length of a length to be cosine of the angle between them.
But I told you another way to do a dog be a x,
B x Plus Ayby.
You get that by writing a as any a x plus j times a y likewise for B and taking
all the different dark products you get when you open up the brackets.
That's where you get a x,
B x plus Ayby there because I.
Dot.
I is one in JLR days one and I'd RJ vanishes for the dark product trust product.
Exactly the opposite.
If you write I times x Cause Day Times a y let's k times Izzy cross product,
but similar things for beats I times be explicitly a times B,
y et cetera.
K Times busy.
That in principle nine terms you can get in the cross product,
three of them will vanish because when you take icrossing you will get zero.
When you take across there,
you will get something Munich Take Jay Cross I you get minus something.
You put them all together.
I won't do this now.
It will look like I times x,
B y minus Ayb x plus the time something in Cape Time,
something I don't,
I don't need this.
I'm not going to dwell on this.
It's good enough for our purposes to know.
The cross product can be visualized as the bactrim.
Perpendicular the two vectors,
farming the product and of length equal to length.
Availing to be sine of the angle between.
Okay.
Okay,
so why did I introduce across product?
Well,
here is the point.
I've introduced Torque as our cross f I hope you know what that means.
If a forces acting at the point with vector are measured from some origin that
are geared,
that forces our that.
Now I'm going to introduce for a single point mass somewhere here and angular
momentum,
which is also going to be a vector previously angular momentum Iomega is not a
vector.
We just saved spinning clockwise or counter.
Now for a single point mass moving in some direction,
I'm going to introduce the angular momentum to be art cross p.
This is an inspired definition and you will find it's a good definition because
things will work out.
What's the first thing I want this definition dissatisfying.
Anybody have an idea of what we expect?
What relation to expect between Torque and l?
Elevate
torque should be the database to avail.
Yeah,
right?
So what are you going to say that?
So I expect if things are working out,
how should be DLD.
So let's see what the l d t is.
The rate of change of angular momentum is going to be the R D t
Christ be less our cross.
The PDT.
Just use the rule of calculus.
I mean you got a product,
you take a little bit of this and then the database to have that.
But d r d t is the velocity price momentum less our cries,
the force,
the rate of change of momentum is the force.
No,
this guy would be like,
that's the torque.
This guy we don't like,
but that'd be zero.
So
you know why that does zero B Crosby
multiplied last few times.
The mass times velocity,
the loss,
the cancer that no.
Yes,
because P is equal to n B where V is the same philosophy,
right?
So velocity and momentum or parallel,
it just connected by a number APP.
But if you take to paddle vectors,
that cross product we'll manage because scientists to zero.
So luckily that drops out and we do have this very nice result that if I defined
I ain't gonna momentum this way,
then great 15 them.
Angular momentum is the torque.
But Tara was defined as art process.
So let me convince you that these definitions than three dimensions are fully
compatible with what we've been doing all this time and tournament.
Let me convince you,
this is not a new,
a brand new definition.
Let's go back to two D and Why ask,
what does all of this look like when I applied to today?
So go to the two dimensions now let's put that in the,
let's take some object.
Take a tiny,
tiny piece of gum stuck to some rotating rigid body first.
What did we say is the angular momentum according to this formula
ain't got momentum is our cross p.
This is our right if a part of the rigid body,
it can only move that way.
Um,
first taking the case where the mass I'm considering is embedded on a rigid
body.
Then when you rotate rotated,
it has to go along a circle with that as the radius.
So the moment than p will look like that and the are measured from any point we
look like this are cross p which is what I'm calling l.
The length available be our cross p for length of our cross which would be our
four p.
Let me write MV
MVP is the tangential velocity here but we both know that that is equal to m
times Omega Times are because of tangential velocity.
There's Omega are that's something weird or long back but then this becomes an
Omega Square are
I'm sorry,
m r squared,
Omega good and Mr squared is the moment to finish.
You have this point mass and Omega is the angular velocity of the point.
That's what we've been using all this time so it's fully compatible with the
definition of angular momentum we had but it's broader than this one.
This was applicable only to bodies which is circling some point because they're
stuck on a rigid body.
That's why there's art I've never changed and it just went round at any
incident.
If there is some omega,
it have some anger moment,
but I want to think of you had to think about the following fact.
Whenever you take a rigid body is made up of many bodies.
Each one of them has angular momentum.
I Omega you added them all up but as a vector,
each one is angular momentum coming out of the blackboard are going into the
blackboard because if r and p lie in the x y plane than our cross be lies along
the z axis either out at in.
That is why both target and angular momentum,
we're treated a scalers and not as vectors because if a vector is constraint the
light up or down the Z axis,
you can forget about the factors that vector.
We just say it's plus if it's up in minus,
if it's done.
That's why in all the early calculations they did today,
but torques,
it was treated as a scalar but actually the park was a vector coming out of the
blackboard or going into the blackboard.
Next I was showing you that the angular momentum you get by this definition when
applied to a rigid body to a tiny speck on at a did body is the same as the
angular momentum we've been using.
But now I want you to think about the following note.
Here's the x,
y plane seen from the top.
That is somebody that is rotating,
that's the SPEC on their body,
which one was the angular momentum written as our cross be was Iomega,
but the SPEC now flies off,
breaks loose and takes off.
That's it.
Still have angular momentum.
If you're doing great body dynamics,
you may not be so sure whether or not it as anger moment because angular
momentum we think of as coming from going round and round something.
Well,
this guy's not going around anything,
right because it's been liberated is taking off like this.
But if you take my definition that angular momentum is our cross Spi,
you'll find that it has angular monitoring even when it's here or there or
anywhere else,
and in fact it's the same angular momentum.
I wanted to tell you why when you are here,
let,
let's take it and epsilon,
before it took off from this rigid body,
it was still stuck to the rigid body.
There's the momentum was in this direction.
Our was in this direction and the angular momentum was our times is momentum p
okay,
what,
what vendors come here when it's come their artists is bigger.
Vector R P is the same.
Vector p is going at a constant speed.
I don't know,
forces on it.
Has the angular momentum changed because the artists become bigger?
But we don't want this art time speed.
If we want our time,
speed,
time,
sine theta,
but our Tatum is in fact,
um,
Saudi Theta is the angle between p and r are Saint Tita is that perpendicular
distance?
That is not changing.
Then maybe I'll draw a better figure so you understand what I mean.
Uh,
take a body in the x,
y plane.
It had just moving like this at constant momentum.
What does angular momentum is what we're asking.
The easiest time to complete the Agora momentum is when it's here.
Then the angular momentum is that distance r times the moment than p time signed
up 90 which is one
if you are over here,
yes.
Then what happens is p is still the same vector.
P R looks like a longer vector but Teva here,
if you put it in our center is still the perpendicular distance.
In other words,
the angular momentum of a particle with respect to some origin.
Yeah,
it's the product of the momentum times.
The perpendicular distance you get by extrapolating is velocity so you can drop
a perpendicular on it,
draw a line through the momentum and drop a perpendicular honored from the audit
in that distance times is momentum is the anger moment,
so every particle,
unless it's going through the center of written finding and the Anglo momentum,
we'll have an anger moment.
It doesn't have to rotate is the main point.
Even a particle and a straight line as Anglo momentum,
but I'm trying to show you the angular momentum here is not changing with time.
It's not changing because even as it moves this component of our,
the art is not changing.
You can see that
no matter where you are,
this distance is not changing.
That's the key to the angular momentum being a constant.
Alright.
No.
If you've got many,
many bodies,
you glue them together or they have interrupt Tomic forces and they form a rigid
body,
then you can use Tobik wills are cross f or d and d.
T.
Yeah,
the l I t t is tell why I ain't got a momentum of body ice changing due to the
torque and body.
I you add everything left hand side would be the total rate of change of angular
momentum.
Right and side will be the total torque.
Yes.
No,
the total torque on the rigid body made up of many point particles.
Even if it's not a rigid body,
just take a bunch of bodies moving around and find the rate of change of total
angular momentum.
That's the sum of the total torics.
You can divide the torque into the external torque and the torque internally due
to the forces of one part of the system on another part,
the system.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm going in the same way as they did with momentum.
The rate of change of total momentum of a system.
It's the external force plus internal forces it remember the internal forces
cancelled in pairs and therefore we could drop that and therefore rate of change
of total moment.
There must be external force for Torque.
You made it like again cancelled the internal forces internal torques because
the forces are opposite but it's not so obvious you can cancel them
because even though the force that I exerted on you when you exert on me are
equal and opposite to find the Torque,
you multiply the force you exert on me cross product with a distance of me from
the origin betters with you is the distance of you from the audit so they don't
necessarily canceling and you can show that only if the fours,
one body et cetera on the other was in the line joining them.
Then that would cancel and angular momentum would be conserved.
So angular momentum.
Conservation requires more than just usual momentum.
Conservation only for the microscopic level forces that bodies exert on other
bodies is in the line.
Joining them is angular momentum conserved.
Fortunately that turns out to be true for every force we know.
Gravitation,
Coulomb's law,
electrostatic forces,
all of them had the property that a exerts a force and be in the lion joining.
So let's take that for granted and then do the last problem I want to do for you
guys,
which is the gyroscope.
Yeah,
so here is the gyro.
Now again,
I have to draw this gyros and other humiliating experience.
I'm going to try to hear to say little tower on with the Gyro is supported.
Yeah,
maybe we can draw it this,
uh,
it's a disk in this case which is spinning like that.
Everybody with me now
that is a little tower on the apex of that.
You take a massless rod if you like for the Gyro here and first of all suppose
is not spinning.
I'm going to,
I'm holding it here and I'm going to let go.
What's going to happen to the Gyro is what we are asked.
Gyro is not spinning.
Everybody should know.
You don't need physics 200 or 100 at anything to know what's going to happen.
You let it go.
It's going to fall.
We want to make sure that agrees with the equation that we have.
How we can tie alpha.
Well,
the torque on this gyro is because the mass of the rod has no mass.
The disc which is sitting there has a mass mg,
so torque is equal to mg times l where l is the length of his rod.
That'll produce an IOL phone.
But let's do the Torque is a vector.
Yeah.
What is the vector torque?
I want you guys to think about that.
Here is are the vector r looks like this,
right horizontal.
The vector mg looks like this free as a vector,
so our cross f which is really not MDL,
but our cross f is the gentle formula be to reduce the stream GL.
Now do the screwdriver rule from art to AMG.
It goes into the board.
So we say the angular momentum of this rod gets an increment pointing into the
board,
which would be very,
very clear that when angular momentum points into the board doesn't mean the
Gyro goes into the board.
It just means the access around with the Jadah rotates is pointing into the
board.
It's another way of saying it rotates like that.
So data will pick up an Alpha,
which we also assign as going into the board.
It'll just fall down.
So if you take a gyro and it doesn't occur to you to spend the Gyro,
you might as well get a piece of stick with an orange at the end.
What makes it interesting is the following fact,
you can spin the gyro now.
Now it's a different ballgame.
Suppose the Gyro now has an initial anger moment.
Which way is it pointing?
It was the first thing you gotta understand.
This is a spinning disk.
Every part of it is spinning and the angular momentum,
every part,
if you do our cross people all point outside.
So one way to find the angular momentum of a spinning disk is to have your
fingers curl along that add extra rotation.
The thumb points in the direction of Anglo moment today I know has an angular
momentum l pointing that way.
Yeah.
Let me look at the top view of this gyro.
The top view of the Gyro is like this.
This is the top of the tower.
It's my gyro in spinning as seen from the top like this and has got an angular
momentum l in this direction.
Good.
This is a pretty dicey thing.
So you might have to go home and read it again.
I don't know how much I can do right now,
but now let us look at the impact of the gravitational torque.
That angular momentum change Delta l is it going to tout times the time Delta t
we agreed was going into the blackboard.
That means this l is getting real contribution delta l in that direction and
that just means the data is going to come to that location.
So what happens is if you have an l to begin with,
you ad with a Delta l like this,
you get the new LPS,
Delta l which is just the rotated l.
That's the way the gyro doesn't fall.
It does get an Ng.
See for static rod got an angular momentum going into the board.
It read me really means is falling down like this,
but if a rotating Jadah got an angular momentum on top of an existing angular
momentum,
the new angular momentum is now just a rotated angular moment.
So when seen from the top,
because I know we'll be doing what's called a precession,
if you support it,
you'll just slowly go round and round with the stip here.
Where does this remind you of anything you've seen before?
Yup.
Uh Huh.
Right when we did the earth rotating around the sun out,
any satellite going around it was the same thing here.
An apple,
if it's not moving,
the force of gravity acts on it costs us an acceleration towards the center.
That means what you,
and I think it means falling toward the center,
but if you take an apple with a huge velocity to begin with,
I had to wait an acceleration towards the center or a tiny increment of velocity
in this direction.
We just give it that velocity.
That's the velocity it has when it does come here.
Same thing with the gyro.
The data desk get the same angular momentum,
Delta l that it would whether or not it was rotating,
but in one case you added the zero and conclude it's going to fall down.
Other case you added twoL and controlled that it'll rotate.
So dado is constantly trying to fall down but it's chasing itself just like this
is constantly trying to fall down and changing itself.
So last thing I wanted calculate is the rate at which it goes round and round.
It's pretty easy calculation.
I will do that and I will let you go.
So let's ask,
the following question is a general was angular momentum l little later l plus
Delta l looks like that this is Delta l
and it rotates an angle.
Delta Theta,
sometimes Delta t.
Then just from the radiums business you've learned,
I think you guys know the Delta l is l time Delta Theta.
If data isn't radio,
that's why I'm cautioning you always thinking radians.
So if you rotate the vector Ben Angle,
Delta Theta,
that segment for small in the segment is El Delta table.
So they might both sites by the time over which happens.
Okay.
Delta Airlines or Delta t on the left hand side is the Torque and this is l
times watch called the precessional frequency Omega sub p.
That's what we are trying to calculate.
So the precessional frequency in this problem is equal to the torque divided by
angular momentum of the gyro.
The torque.
Now we can put the numbers in his AMG times.
L Anglo momentum.
The gyro is some one half Iomega square one half.
I'm sorry,
Time's Iomega.
Okay,
so this is unfortunately we don't have the ability to demonstrate anything in
this room.
But if you looked at the stuff we have in Sloan,
if you take a big gyro and you spin it,
you suspend one and on the tip of a tower and it's spinning like this,
you are some weight to it.
We'll find a stodge going around.
The data is not spinning,
it'll just fall down.
If it's spinning,
it's got an angular momentum in that direction to which it gets an increment in
that direction.
So it goes on rotating,
and if you add more weights,
the gyro,
it'll rotate faster because if you add more weights,
the gyro besides its own mass,
you will increase this quantity.
All right,
so we are done with the nasty parts.
The next week we start relativity so that you guys can get something more
contemporary.